[Music]
you were there during the making but are
we ready for what I'm expecting are we
ready for this I can't talk for you but
I'm not ready I am NOT ready for what is
about to occur I'm not I'm not the world
is ready for Black Panther Lupita
Nyong'o pulled out all the stops at the
film's LA premiere Monday night looking
royal in purple this is custom Versace
we got the memo about the dress code and
we were inspired by vibranium and yeah
the Versace did what Versace does you
get to decide it was quite astounding to
shoot it was I remember it was one of
those moments on set where we were like
wow this isn't it like nothing else
we've ever seen
this gorgeous gorgeous waterfall and
there was a conference of extras
everywhere and dramas playing and every
one of these incredible costumes and
then you know we just like Griff to like
drop it like it's hot the blue tape do
you feel at all an extra sense of we
gotta get this right we're doing it for
people who have been waiting for a movie
like this I mean I feel like it's
there's not been nothing like it so of
course with that comes deep sense of
responsibility it's like you're the
first to do something like this on this
level so yeah it's definitely something
you feel will challenge by because
there's no rulebook for it I know I mean
they've been many Marvel movies but none
like this so we're writing the rule book
of makanda and black panther okay so
I've been going down the list
I asked Ava Ava said ask ISA ass ISA ISA
set ass Lupita and asked Brianna so
where are we in this fantasy movie that
now we all are clamoring to see God guys
can you tell me yeah ask him ask him is
there any movement I know you guys are
still talking but in
mangies the vault you are the vault
[Music]